alors à paris la love story parce qu'en
fermant tous les people se la chaussée
qui a pu aujourd'hui il a eu un pull
bear total alors on à lola marois au
regard de ce qu'elle a raconté ya pas
longtemps je sais c'est jordan de luxe
bassékou plus libre et jean marie bigard
fameuses portes au programme aussi
s'agir bien avec jean marie bigard
uriner j'aime sur certaines choses que
je trouve absurde c'est à dire où tout à
coup par exemple d'avoir embrassé un mec
dans la série es tu vas me dire j'éteins
la télé c'est bon j'ai pour lui de voir
ça j'aime pas envoyé dire on n'est pas
un couple libre parce que c'est pas vrai
si c'est un truc ponctuelles un écart
une fois comme ça je préférerais ne pas
savoir parce que j'ai c'est vrai que
j'ai eu ni fierté que monsieur me
sentirai salies je dirais pas que c'est
un accord tacite parce que on se donne
pas le droit d'aller voir ailleurs mais
on se dit que si un jour quelque chose
devait arriver faut pas le dire à
l'autre bas à moins que voilà personne
n'est à l'abri d'un faux pas du tout des
rencontres
de fuir et super 4 mais c'est bien de
dire ça comme ça dans ton dessin fait ce
qu'il veut dans sa vie sexuelle de
savoir en fait qui racontera le plus
détails sur sa culotte wallace et jordan
lui qui lui demandons quelle heure ils
font très flou rien qui va le faire dans
closer
d'infos assure renault et on en cherche
pas spécialement très honnête béchamel
je sais que c'est beaucoup plus libres
attention dexia indique t elle dit on
est libre d'aller sortir avec ses amis
voilà on n'est pas où c'est touche pas
mais elle dit pas on compte les cas un
coup de canif dans le contrat une fois
la vie de 10 ans on dirait plus un appel
on dirait plus une go c'est un coup de
pied d'un contrat chez vous ça passe ou
pas six mois ouais bah non pas du tout à
ça mais parce qu'on a besoin de vous
plonger en coupe je ressens rien au
chômage que les femmes zen après 40 ans
50 ans de vie commune mais sinon et là
c'est 40 ont des cartes pas car on tombe
de haut
[Applaudissements]
et
des bons helvétiques qui vendent la
petite couronne on connaît pas
s'habiller elle est célibataire
non non on emploie en couple
non pas du tout français brême ah oui et
non déjà que j'ai pas eu le temps pourra
alors lui libre mais elle ne s'est pas
être moi je pense juste quand même un
très bon compagnon de vie pour elle mais
je pense pas qu'elle fasse des
commerçants
mais quelqu'un qui est mieux que soi non
je sais pas j'ai pas du tout de ça mais
je pense que monsieur rsa et non non je
pense qu'il est qu'ils vendaient moins
de l'upa tsige pour elle car mon avis
doit et passionné oui ou non il ya des
il ya des personnes qui ont 60 70 ans
qui ont dépisté craindre hélas rival
laurent gbagbo c'est une bourde encore
bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
tu peux tu les deux là on s'en fout un
peu en vrai elle ni quand même
globalement que de la mer chasse que
lola marois c'est qu'
une émission que je produisais qui
s'appelle les people passent le bac sur
nrj 12 il ya cinq ans on la voulait pas
l on voulait lui et pour l'avoir lui il
fallait qu'on est elle et j'ai vécu mais
l'horreur sans quoi pendant un mois lui
barrer fou furieux je me suis même fait
déchirer la gueule comme bigard a pu me
déchirer la gueule un jour ça qu'il est
parti l'avait les bennes rouges comme ça
qu'on avait dix minutes de retard avec
mon associé à l'époque dans leur
appartement aux invalides et le mec il a
pété les coupes je pense que il est
barré je pense qu'ils traitent les
câbles et c'est pour ça qu'ils vont bien
ensemble les deux sont aussi vulgaire
elle fait sa carrière grâce mais c'est
vrai que de temps en temps ils
récupèrent peau elle voit la barre
d'espacé bonne ça n'engage pas
encore
commencé non mais parce que j'aime ça
j'aime pas ces gens qui passent leur
temps et bigard il devenu fou depuis
quelques années on le voit bien je
prends même pas de son combat depuis
deux ans c'est juste des gens qui ont de
la merde dans le cerveau par dont ils
sont
s'écoute et ils ont de la merde dans le
cerveau au sens ils sont tout le temps
où une forme d'agressivité de revendeurs
de mai
qui supportent plus d'être numéro un eh
ben il a qualifié d' je me maquille
encore on vieillit mal il prend des
combats avec cet été encore il quand il
fait des blagues et tout ce qui
l'afer a devancé deux puteaux
et la tire c'est des gens c'est des gens
qu'on ait courtoisie à mon sens ni
dignité et je pense que cette
déclaration une fois de plus montré à
quel point elle est juste pas dit nous
l'avons bien que leurs emplois du temps
en temps j'ai des gens mais moi j'adore
banon n'a plus rien à [ __ ] il fait
très discret